hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are back at the capablanca
saga are checking up on our girlfriend
Jose Raul and well like I said we're
back at the 1918 tournament of New York
it's around 11:00 and it's very rare
that we can show a photo of Blanca
actually playing a certain game but here
is just such a case where we actually do
have a photo of this game being played
we already showed it when we started the
1918 tournament of New York saying that
it's a game from round 11 but for those
of you who are maybe just joining us
here it is capablanca vs all score
highest well Oscar highest vs.
capablanca there you have it kappa
blanka with the black pieces on board
one behind them you have bought a cost
issue versus morrison and in the far
back although you can see marshall
really it's a Janoski versus Frank James
Marshall so let's just enjoy that for a
moment and then now we're returning to
the tournament Capablanca still without
a single loss like I said this is round
11 we're gonna be showing two more games
from this tournament and then we're
gonna check out the standings and well
see where we go from there but like we
said probably two Kevon has matched with
Borislav Kostich and then to the world
chess championship match with a manual
ask her that being said let's check out
this very intriguing game has opened
with e4 with E 5 Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 we have Knight to c3 and now Knight
to f6 the four Knights defense is on the
board and Bishop to b5 by high so we
have d6 d4 Bishop to d7
now the knight is no longer pinned and
here we have Bishop to e3 and now he
captures on d4 and it's very interesting
this is only move a6 has been played by
capablanca and this position has never
been reached again so after this game
this ecaps force on d4 position has
never again occurred anywhere in any
tournament well any tournament that you
know no it's not the moves of the games
yeah but you know but okay it's a not a
popular open opening anymore and
stronger continues have been found but
still very interesting night capture
Sundy for grabbing that point and here
just Bishop d7 Capablanca prepares to
castle
we have castles by highest castles
capablanca and the now h3 just taking
away the g4 square from blacks night and
Bishop and now Knight captures on d4 and
here Queen captures on d4 if you wanna
put in the in between Bishop captures
and d7 then kappa blanka had night
captures on c2 in mind where he would
have to capture and then after night
recapture she would just be down upon as
white so after night capture Sun before
we have Queen captures on d4 as planned
Bishop captures on b5 and Knight
captures and now Knights to b7 now
capablanca has ideas of going to either
c5 or a 5 or maybe even to be 6 + c4 if
it would be possible in the future we
have Queen to c3 now and now comes c6
pushing the knight back Knight study for
and out Bishop to f6 now you don't want
your Queen to be on this diagonal so
Queen to d2 and now finally nice to b6
with ideas of maybe coming to c4 we have
c3 by highest allowing this Knight to c4
jump which Capablanca if he decided to
do so could eliminate blacks dark square
Bishop but here a couple monk also
agrees that the knight is stronger than
the bishop here we have rook to e8
developing while attacking d4 pawn and
now Queen to d3 just defending with d5
finally a free move and he captures on
d5 Queen captures on d5 and now Queen to
f5 our highest offers a trade of Queens
and here Capablanca declines he prefers
to keep the Queen's on the board for the
moment if the wife Queen moves to some
unfavorable position then he can even
just continuing doubling up on the
e-file nice and continue in the game but
here has goes Queen to f3 he wants to
trade Queens and night the C for backup
Ivanka he says ok I'm done with trading
Queens might I like my position better
and here if you if you trade Queens
which did happen in the game and we're
gonna show that but the other idea is
Bishop to F for allowing rook to e4 or
or maybe just trading and then going
about it but here
blacks position is somewhat better like
that's control more space so you want to
remove the Queens of the board so here
Queen captures on d5 is played
we have rook a person d5 and now rook a
to be one just defending that
be one bond and here again Capablanca
has to decide how to go about this you
can go rook to e8 continue playing this
game you can decide to go Knight
captures on e3 and create an isolated a
pawn but Capablanca decides to go about
it differently here okay if you play
Knight captures here F captures and then
rook to e8 for example then you get rook
beat e one and now the white knight is
perfectly fine here you either have to
eliminate it and then fix White's pawn
structure or if you push c5 maybe try to
infiltrate Knight f3 the knight is
controlling the D 2 square
you're not infiltrating here and the
white will have d 4 D 5 e 45 very soon
so capablanca has a different idea first
Bishop captures on d4 like couple
already said the knight is stronger than
the bishop here we have a C capture
stand before the point being that you
cannot play Bishop captures to keep your
pawn structure intact because Knight d2
would attack both rooks and black would
win material here so after Bishop
captures we have seek after Sun before
and now kappa blanka will start his
grind he will play he played this game
against the isolated D pawn we have rook
to e8 first look after he won and now f6
I'm just preparing to bring the King
into the game b3 pushing the knight back
Knights to a 3 and now rugby to see one
King to f7 kappa blanka starts bringing
the King into the game rook eat the d1
now and now rook eat a d8 so piling up
on the d4 pawn the idea is not b5 and
winning the pawn rook to d2 now you can
defend it with either rook C 2 D 1 or
even look to c4 depending on on the mood
rook or Knight to b5 attacking the pawn
and now rook the c4 the pawn is defended
but all of whites pieces are now tied
down into the defense of the d4 pawn
with King to e6 capablanca starts
bringing the King deeper into the
position and now g4 not allowing the
King to move any closer
so f5 by Capablanca with f3 and now just
look to f8 there is no longer need for
the moment to keep the pressure on the D
file so kappa blanka hopes to open up
the F file with King to g2 highest also
wants to increase the activity of Ace
King and now f4
pushing the bishop
back we have got F 2 and now look back
to D 8 and we have a 4 now pushing the
night back webknights the c7 so now
there are there aren't three attackers
against the d4 pawn white will also be
able to move some of the pieces with b4
first now comes a six and here look to e
to check King to d7 and now comes looked
efore going after the f4 pawn Capablanca
defends that you can either go rook a
faith or g5 s capablanca did in the game
and now h4 now with h6 and H captures in
g 5h captures and now look back to see
one not with ideas of even infiltrating
on the seventh rank would look to H 1
followed by erupt h7 check we have a 5
now by capablanca hoping that white
characters and then you can just gobble
up all of the points on the Queen side
and here rook to be one was played
Bishop to e1 seems to be a little bit
better because now even if kappa blanka
captures then Bishop captures will be
very strong because you already control
the e7 square and black doesn't have a
move to consolidate you would have to
react to this first you you will not be
able to go b5 or roof traits or
something like that the quick will go
for the a for pawn so would be an
improvement to look to be one to move
highest plate but it's still it's still
very much playable a captures done
before by kappa blanka rook captures and
before and now king to see it now kappa
blanka wants to bring his king all the
way here and then push b5 we have rook
to eat oh now comes rook a to the d7 we
have looked the c4 just waiting to see
what a couple of anka will do rook 7 to
d6 now and now look back to before we
have nice to east 6 now again with a
triple attack against the d4 pawn and
just rook to e4 defending I rock the d2
was also also possible we have team to
b8 now a couple manga starts bringing
the King over to the key a queen side
rook back to e 1 and now comes Knight to
d8 we have looked back to e 2 now comes
roof to d7 rook to e1 and now King to a7
we have rook to e2 now comes King to a6
and here just looked
and here look seven to d6 and here rook
to e7 and now the problem would move
like king to a5 yes you would very much
win da for pawn but you don't really
gain anything by it
if King captures just rook to e2 and how
do you prevent checkmate here you have
to go King a3 but then just rock the
beat you and you will not be able to
escape perpetual whatever you play
you're just gonna get checked King moves
again rook here threatening mate again
you would have to repeat check moves
again threatening mate and so on and so
on it would be a a draw by by repetition
so here kappa blanka goes b5 as planned
and now of course you want captures and
captures this is the plan but now look
to e2 this rook is now hoping of coming
here and the now comes Knight to e6
again putting pressure to the d4 pawn
and here the problem would rotate to is
that the king can just move King to b6
and you don't really gain anything you
will again have to trade here because if
you push a 5 then you have a problem
King a 6 and you can no longer keep
defending the a 5 point and the d4 pawn
the rook well cannot be in both places
at once so you will lose the pawn here
and the game so after night he sets with
a cap person B 5c captor son B 5 now
well second part of capo Blancas plan
has been completed now he does have a
past beep on he will now try to push it
away with 98-96 and start pushing the
the past be point rook to a to check we
have king to b6 and now comes Luke the
c2 and here well trying to somewhat
strict couple on if you capture here
then you lose the game but you know it's
maybe not all that obvious but feel free
to pause the video and try to see why
you lose the game if you capture this
pawn now for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you are an
excellent
trapper of knights and for the Duke who
just won't enjoy the show
rook the c4 this pawn is pinned you
cannot capture and you cannot move the
knight because it's pinned C so next
move white we'll just play rook captures
here when a piece and win the game so
couple monk obviously not falling for
that we have looked a d7 now comes route
back to C 1 and now Knight to d8 the
night will be much more active on c6 as
it will again
the default phone but also support the
past beep on rook to be to with Knight
to c6 and now rook C to be one rook to
a7 capablanca now also hopes of
infiltrating on the Queen side rook to
e1 and now comes rope the a4 again a
much more active Square for the rook you
control much more space while also
attacking the d4 pawn and look the e6
ice finds a nice active move to defend
the pawn as now the knight is pinned
we've looked the c4 and now comes Luke
to f6 preparing group to a 5 highest
wants to trade rooks and create a past F
pawn b4 kappa blanka starts pushing his
passed pawn and now Luke to f5 and here
couple monka says no way you just go
away 97 or you can capture and then
we're gonna trade here no passed pawn
for you rook to f7 and now Knight back
to c8 and here rooked f8 attacking the
denied also instead of this you could
have just gone back rook to a5 but has
also interested in beating Capablanca he
doesn't just want to draw as he already
did defeated him we've shown the game in
the rice tournament in the rice Memorial
Tournament of New York two years ago the
only game Capablanca lost after a couple
Monica started his legendary streak but
has already showed that he can defeat
kappa blanka and he wants to do it again
with King to b5 and now comes rogue back
to f6 looked a c1 sorry rook to c1 and
now rook to f5 again going for a trade
and Knight back to be 16 ok we can trade
but for trading on d5 rook back to f7
and now comes Knight to d7 route back to
f5 and now well it's a little bit
different it's no longer the same
position as when the night was on b6 and
this rook wasn't and c1 but here it just
doesn't work for white anymore here
couple monk I just played characters on
f5 and here we have G captures on f5 yes
now why does have a passed pawn but
black couple mangas plan is clear we
have Knight to f6 the king is now coming
all the way here and you will start
pushing your passport so white has to
react to this first rook to e2 but now
just b3
we've looked
7.now with ideas that if one is pushed
to be too you can play rugby 7 check and
win the pawn but rook the c2 now the
pawn on v2 will be protected
rook the b7 check King to c4 rook the c7
check King to d3 now and rook to b7
we've beat you by capablanca and now
comes Luke to be for waiting to see what
Capablanca will do with Knights the d5
and here f6 by highest saying okay if
you capture my rook I'm getting a queen
here but capablanca says I'm not
interested in your pawn or your rook I'm
going for mate nights the e3 check the
bishop is pinned so you cannot capture
we have came to h3 and now rook captures
on f2 capablanca doesn't care about the
past pawn anymore highest pushes f7 and
here just rook captures on f3 with check
King to h2 we have looked to have to
check King to G 1 and here it really all
just falls apart for Oscar highs
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the mating sequence I'll
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
checkmater in six and for those if you
just want to enjoy the show the movies
of course rook to f1 check King to h2
and now just G for the planet pawn to g3
and the rook to h1 mate for example if
you bring your Queen into the game g3
checking h3 and rook to h1 mate but this
is not the best defensive line for white
so even with the best defense after g4
you can go rook the b3 check and now
after the King moves you can play rook
captures night but it's still the same
rook F to check King G 1 and now pawn
captures rook and now you no longer care
what white place you even control the f8
Square but it's really not that
important whatever white plays you can
bring a queen into the game map just
point to B 1 you can bring a queen or a
rook its mate and of course that's
that's all all that's needed so after
King to g1 highest resigned and yet
another brilliant victory for josé raúl
capablanca who is still dominating this
tournament without a single loss and
just you know doing what he does best
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed that I would like to thank
Joseph Bisset assignment Hawk Dan
O'Hanlon header caught him and
Sims for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check too on my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon we're
continuing the Capablanca saga like we
mentioned two more games in this
tournament then a match would bore a
claw stitch and then we're continuing
the World Chess Championship match
against Emmanuel asker so once again I
do hope you enjoyed it and I will see
you soon have an excellent rest of your
day